thanks very much so how can we use big
data and crowdsourcing to improve
population health monitoring I'm sure
you're all aware of the Ebola outbreaks
that are going on right now in Africa
but I want to take you back in time to
March 14th this is one a french-language
news article surfaced of a mysterious
illness that killed eight people and had
symptoms of fever and bleeding five days
later it was up to 23 deaths attributed
to this mysterious illness this is the
day that samples are first sent off to
France and Senegal for laboratory
analysis a week later it was up to 29
deaths eight days later the outbreak had
gone international now with a case
appearing in Sierra Leone and then a
full nine days later you have the first
official wh 0 announcement confirming
that the outbreak was in fact Ebola
virus and confirming a 29 deaths
including two in the capital city of
Guinea so now fast-forward to yesterday
this is the this is September third I
now have thousands of cases and over a
thousand deaths to outbreaks now all the
information that I just showed you is
actually freely available on our website
health map org slash Ebola it's a
centralized place for comprehensive easy
to access information on the outbreak
and it's continually updated in near
real-time so basically I review the the
world of information as a spectrum from
data sources that are that are noisy but
produced signals rapidly on the left end
and you're more validated sources like
health officials or things emerge more
slowly but they're more reliable and
basically our goal is to kind of shift
to the left longest spectrum sake how
can we tap into these noisy data sources
to determine these these early signals
and we call this concept digital disease
detection so basically in your
traditional public health reporting
model you have this sort of this flow of
information where some that something
happens in the general population say
someone gets sick and then I think they
visit a clinician maybe the astute
clinician notices something amiss and
reports that to a local Health Authority
they then report that to a National
Health Authority and then they in turn
report that to an international health
authority and then the system is is very
important and valuable but the challenge
is that there's a delay that's
introduced in each step of the process
so we contrast that with the new world
of digital disease detection where
information really blows freely
throughout the network through across
all these different players so this is
the health map website we cover all
different types of infectious disease
foodborne illness respiratory diseases
any type of infectious disease and the
way it works is basically we have a
crawler that goes out around the clock
collecting data from hundreds of
thousands of different sources across 15
different languages you pull these into
our database and we use our natural
language processing technology to
identify disease and location for each
event as well as other types of metadata
that we can apply to the events we also
use a machine learning filtering system
basically you know when you search for
disease related keywords you're also
going to get things maybe that are about
scientific findings about the disease or
vaccination campaigns or an outbreak of
home runs or justin bieber fever so
that's what this process is kind of it's
filtering out the information so that
we're capturing data that refers to
actual ongoing outbreaks and then we
also apply a clustering algorithm to
group duplet stoop lacate's together and
then we apply a significance rating to
the event the curve sort of characterize
the importance of the event and then we
pushed all that information directly to
health mapped org where it's freely
available for our users and then another
key
important part of this process is that
we also have a team of multilingual
analysts that review the data that in
that that refined the characterizations
so the first real test of the system
came in 2009 with the emergence of
influenza h1n1 and the first signal that
we derived for h1n1 came from a local
spanish-language newspaper in Veracruz
Mexico talking about a mysterious
respiratory illness that has affected
2,000 of the 3,000 residents of a small
village now of course h1n1 went on to
chief pandemic status spread throughout
the world and actually what's what's
notable about this chart is not the fact
that h1n1 spread throughout the world
but that this is generated using solely
informal data sources so news media and
other types of publicly available
information right so most recently we've
done some work looking at social media
data around h7n9 outbreak that occurred
in China last year and then another
aspect that we're incorporating is
looking at other data layers that we can
integrate with this with our data so in
this case we're looking at data around
volume of transportation flow around the
world and then superimposing that with
MERS coronavirus event data to generate
risk maps for where where the virus
might spread and then another thing that
we're looking at in addition to you
actual outbreaks of disease is what are
the drivers of infectious disease so one
key area is people's attitudes and
beliefs around vaccines so vaccines are
very important for controlling
infectious disease so we apply the same
technology to look at what people are
saying about vaccines and whether they
have positive or negative views towards
them so we have this map which is our
vaccine sentiment map and we can create
this kind of matrix of by country and by
disease as to what people are saying
about vaccines and it doesn't stop here
we've also done projects looking at
things like wildlife trades you have
these exotic animals that
smuggled across borders they often carry
disease he also looked at the different
conflict situations and other other
factors like that but there's also a
limitation to this to this text mining
approach you're always going to have
gaps in data and so one of the things
that we've done to try to try to address
these gaps is actually to engage
directly with users so this is our
crowdsourcing concept that we've also
integrated into health map and our first
foray into this area was with the
release of our mobile app which is
called outbreaks near me and what the
app does allow you to get up-to-date
outbreak information tailored to your
location and it also allows you to
submit a report directly into the system
so if you know of an outbreak that's
happening in your area you can report it
directly to health map and actually
during the h1n1 outbreak the app was
briefly the top free app in the itunes
store and we've been able to collect
reports from all over the world and we
were also able to create basically an
indicator value for flu activity based
on the aggregate volume of reports for
the coming from people that are using
the mobile app which tracks roughly with
the CDC data which is a kind of the
traditional method for influenza
surveillance in the United States and
more most recently our crowdsourcing
project is called flew near you where we
really what we're trying to do with this
is address one of the key problems of
outbreaks near me which is the
denominator problem so when you when
you're trying to measure disease and
you're relying on people to make
spontaneous reports the problem is that
you don't know who's not sick and with
this system we have people sign up then
every week they get a very quick survey
basically says you know have you
experienced any symptoms over the past
week and if not you just check off no
it's very quick and if you have then you
check off you know you had coughing
fever or other types of symptoms like
that and this allows us to create a
nationwide map of flu activity just
based on
people's direct reports into the system
and then also likewise allows us to
create this indicator value of flu
activity for the country which also
tracks pretty well with the traditional
influenza tracking systems and thanks to
some media coverage we've been able to
get a lot of engagement with the system
we have well over a hundred thousand
people that are enrolled in this flu
near you system right now another area
of expansion for this system is our go
viral initiative so what we're actually
doing here is taking advantage of the
latest advances in a point of care
diagnostic tools so we recruit people
into the system just as we would for flu
near you when you sign up you get a kit
in the mail and then you fill out your
survey just in the same way and then if
you're sick you can use this kid at home
to collect a sample and then you send
that in to the lab for processing you
have this panel of common respiratory
pathogens and then within one to two
weeks you can get that result back to
you and then populate this map which
creates a map not only of flu symptoms
but also of actual path underlying
pathogens and this is still really in
the preliminary phases so we really
don't have a lot of data but we've done
kind of a proof-of-concept will be
Illustrated that we can actually do this
and actually show some of the diversity
of pathogens that that are out there so
if X just disease is really kind of the
foundation of this work but we've also
expanded into looking at pharmaceutical
products so this is another of our
crowdsourcing project this is a website
called street RX basically you come to
the site and you can put in any price
for a prescription drug but this is
actually for black market prices so
these are typically drugs of abuse so
things like oxycontin or adderall or
other painkillers that are actually kind
of traded illicitly
without a prescription and we've been
able to actually cross validate the
prices that we get just from the users
on our site with other sources of the
data including tapping data from the
so-called dark web in this case the Silk
Road black market marketplace another
thing that we can look at with this data
is the so-called abuse to turn
formulations so this is where in the
pharmaceutical company say this is for
oxycontin creates a new version of the
same drug where they make the pill
difficult to crush make it difficult to
extract and concentrate the active
ingredient to deter people from abusing
it and the question as well is that
actually effective and what we've what
we can show is that it is effective
because you can see that there's a
significant drop in a street value for
the abuse-deterrent formulation as
compared with the original another area
that we're looking at is the question of
medication safety so medication side
effects so the modern era of medication
safety practice really started with a
phalidomide disaster of late 1950s so
this is a drug that is used to treat
nausea and it was given to pregnant
women with the unfortunate side effect
of causing these really debilitating
birth defects and babies born of these
mothers and what's what's interesting is
that this this drug was you you know
introduced to the mark in 1957 and then
withdrawn worldwide 1962 that was never
approved in the u.s. encountered a
roughly 10,000 victims but there the the
the case has really persisted into into
the present time so even 50 years later
we're still prosecuting civil cases
around around flutamide meanwhile half
of americans take a prescription drug
half of approved drugs have serious side
effects that are not identified before
they're approved and a quarter of people
taking drugs have some form of adverse
events and three percent of those are
serious so you put all those numbers
together it means roughly one to two
percent of the u.s. population as a
whole is actually experiencing serious
medication side effects as we speak
meanwhile you have a problem of massive
underreporting so most of the reports
that go to the FDA come from clinicians
or pharmaceutical companies there
there's a lot of paperwork involved in
filling out forms doctors don't want to
fill out the forms I don't blame them so
with our midwatch or social project with
the FDA what we're doing is actually
looking at social media to say well how
can we collect data on people just
complaining in public forums online
about their experiences with medications
so these are a few examples from Twitter
people talking about specific products
and the effects that they have so again
we use our natural language processing
technology to identify products and then
symptoms and we are able to take the
colloquial terms that people use to talk
about their symptoms and map those to a
medical dictionary which is called
meddra so there's some challenges here
because we have to deal with typos
people just typing in their social media
posts just just spelling variations
invented words you know things that only
appear in social media and then also the
kind of metaphorical way in which people
speak you know when they're when they're
just speaking colloquy these are so
these are things that you know would
never appear in a medical record or in a
clinical context so we put all those
together into our system and then we're
able to map those concepts back into the
kind of the more formalized clinical
taxonomy so as you might expect you know
the vast majority of mentions of
products online I really are not about
actually people complaining about the
side effects of the medication so again
we use our machine learning technology
to extract this sort of three to four
percent of product mentions where people
are actually talking about some sort of
symptom that they attribute to the
product
so just to look at a couple of examples
so this is this is zoloft and on the
left-hand side is social media data sort
of organized roughly into broad symptom
categories and the right-hand side is
the traditional FDA data collection
method and in this case there's a rough
concordance between the two sources sort
of the things that people report
basically fall into the same basket by
contrast you to look at a drug like
accutane there's a lot less concordance
here and one of the patterns that we've
seen is in a lot of cases that drugs
that have more mild side effects those
tend to be reported much more in social
media so you know say accutane is giving
you dry skin you might go onto Twitter
and complain to your friends about it
that's not something that a doctor is
going to fill out an eight page form to
submit to the FDA say that you have dry
skin problem from the drug so that's
that's another interesting factor that
we're picking on now in this product you
also engaged our crowdsourcing concept
as well too rather than just passively
collecting data from public posts we
want to engage directly with users so
one of the things we can do is use our
machine learning to identify these posts
and then we can actually contact the
person directly and invite them to
submit a more detailed report about
exactly what happened with the product
and that would be through our med
watcher app which is available at
medwatch org and on iphone and android
which allows you to track up-to-date
safety information on your products of
interest and then it also allows you to
fill out a very quick and simple form
where you can report on your experience
with medication so I'm just going to
talk through a couple of examples of
data that we've collected through this
crowd sourcing system so this is a
report for a cancer drug called casodex
and a couple of interesting things here
so this is a report from a clinician a
nurse practitioner but the patient in
this case was actually the person's fun
so it was not their patient and what's
also interesting is that it's noted that
the cause of death officially lists only
the cancer so again you have this
problem of underreporting of these types
of side effects and in this case this is
a liver failure that was attributed to
to the drug and actually this is a known
risk for this particular product but
very few cases have actually been
concretely identified so any case of
this happening be of tremendous interest
to researchers and to to medical
practitioners another product that we've
looked at a lot is this is actually a
medical device so this is permanent
implantable birth control it's these two
little metal coils that actually go into
the the fallopian tubes that block
fertilization now this this product
interestingly basically sort of sailed
through through clinical trials without
really having many any major risks
identified through that testing process
we've had over a thousand reports to
date people's experiences with this
product and these are just a couple of
examples out of really just a laundry
list of kind of very severe symptoms
that people have experienced with this
so bleeding abdominal pain tingling
mental fog infections all kinds of all
kinds of different effects including of
course or maybe not of course but also
unwanted pregnancies despite this being
rated as a highly effective permanent
birth control and then finally what we
could do with these with these reports
that we've collected from users is again
compare that to what we see in the
traditional FDA safety reporting system
so this is taking a sampling from each
system and actually in this case we did
it across 60 for symptom categories so
fairly granular comparison and we
did see hi concordance between what
people were complaining about through
our crowdsourcing system versus the more
formalized traditional FDA system so all
this work is possible thanks to a great
team that we have in our research group
so I want to be sure to thank them and
happy to take any questions we also have
data sets available people are
interested in working with us happy to
share our data we also have real-time
feeds available depending on what you
want to do and so I'll take any
questions thank you